this goes to the idea of the dialogue
and the pushback against a lot of
scientific evidence what will you listen
for in your Paris at the December
meetings so in the economic outlook this
so that we just launched today we
address the issue of you know it's we
can't we can't do anything on climate
change right now we can't have policy
because the economy the global economy
is fragile and we address that head-on
in one of the chapters second chapter
and as well as in the main text and said
you know there are a lot of things that
we can do now that actually are pro
growth and pro climate and we give a lot
of examples about what countries have
already done that have been pro-growth
for their economies and pro climate so
that's the first thing that I think we
have to get off the table that you know
climate change is the anti growth now
the anti-science well that's you know
that's a really tough one and I think
everybody who's going to be in Paris is
pro science so I think that by virtue
there be people there to push back I
mean Francine to me that's one of the
big questions is as ever everybody's on
the same page in Paris right I think
everybody's on the same page with three
point with regard to the science they're
not on the same page with regard to the
policy but you know I think that there's
the French have you know been working
very hard behind the scenes to get an
agreement you know we're focusing on
incentives getting the price is right
and then following in on the policies if
we could at least get another factor
which is complexity there's such
complexity of existing policies in many
countries that simply occur simplifying
them would get us a long way towards an
improved